[Music]  Kim Kardashian wasn't kidding about her  flu diet the reality stars stepped out  in LA on Tuesday night in a sports bra  and nude leggings prompting sister Chloe  to post on Instagram hands-down best  body ever I have to get my together  if this isn't motivation then I don't  know what is Keeks you look amazing  I'm happy and I feel confident and I'm  very happy  Kim received backlash when she tweeted  that having the flu was an amazing diet  causing her to lose an additional six  pounds  she's since deleted the tweet meanwhile  Kim's sister Kourtney and ex Scott  Disick may have split up nearly two  years ago but still can have fun  together on Tuesday the two celebrated  courts 38th birthday at Disney  California Adventure in Anaheim  California and were snapped front and  center on a California screamin  rollercoaster  [Music]  you